vous avez une taie deux sociétés une en
france une dans un autre pays de l'union
européenne votre société allemande
achète pour un million d'euros de quotas
carbone sur le marché bull ext comme ça
un échange entre deux pays de l'union
européenne y'a pas de thé vert ensuite
votre société allemande revend ses
quotas à votre société basée en france
et maintenant votre société française
revendre le tout à bluenext comme les
deux sont basés en france la tva
s'applique et vous recevez un million 2
en principe ces deux cent mille euros de
tva vous devez leur verser à l'état sauf
si vous disparaissez et que vous
renvoyer cet argent dans des comptes
offshore en quelques minutes vous avez
donc gagner enfin voler deux cent mille
euros voilà alors c'est bien expliqué
allan gregg zaoui c'est quoi pour nos
téléspectateurs
cette histoire de taxe carbone de cette
escroquerie expliquent ils à voile a
réexpliqué à nous pour les gens qui nous
regardent bah c'est suite aux accords de
kyoto d'accord c'est ça ils ont décidé
d'instaurer un marché de régulation pour
les pollueurs tous les trains toutes les
usines qu'on voit là les cheminées qu'on
voit la porte de bercy qui envoie de la
fumée dans le co2 est évident et c'était
d'imposer à tous les pollueurs et des
restrictions de quotas de carbone ils
devaient pas dépasser un certain nombre
si jamais ils dépassés ils étaient
obligés d'acheter ce qui la dépasser
s'il avait fait des efforts de
pour polluer moins et ben l'excédent de
quotas qu'on leur avait alloué pouvaient
les vendre et la faille qui a eu c'est
que ils ont appliqué la tva sur ses
quotas là qui sont en fait virtuelle
parce que quand vous transférez un quota
d'un compte à un autre qu'on a un autre
compte
les changes se fait aussi rapidement que
l'envoi d'un sms d'accord donc c'est ça
voilà donc là on parle voilà par exemple
on voit une transaction de 200000 euros
et c'était comme ça ils peuvent en avoir
3 4 comme ça dans la journée et ça donc
ça paye ils sont mille euros dans le pré
visites vous qui avez démarré c'est ce
qu'on dit dans le sol ivoirien et marco
après fou marco au départ vous dit vous
vous saviez pas ce que c'était en fait
l'histoire non j'ai vu dans le
documentaire on savait rien de tout ça
vraiment rires non mais moi je suis un
affairiste et un jour chaud restant
comme ça et je vois des belles voitures
passer à une équipe donc je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qui se passe sap losail et je
vois un mec qui s'appelle mike tweed qui
est mon ami et je le voit descendre une
très belle voiture et lui dit qu'est ce
tu feras en ce moment il m'a dit tout va
bien donc j'ai pris un billet je suis
parti quelque part dans un pays et j'ai
vu que ça se passait très très bien et
là j'ai attaqué j'ai avancé
voilà je
c'était beau c'était bon c'était de
folie mais il ya une chose que je vais
te dire je te tutoie syrie comme
d'habitude tu m'excuses ses marques il
ya une chose que je te dire que c'est on
parle de milliards on parle de tout ce
que tu veux mais ya trois choses qu'il
faut savoir c'est que il ya une tonne de
frais mais non c'est non non non non non
non non non c'est la vérité ça veut dire
il faut pas croire que deux cent mille
euros tugal 200000 euros parce que pour
mettre de la marchandise sur le plateau
il faut absolument perdre de l'argent
dessus pour se racheter à nous mêmes
d'accord donc c'est pour ça deux cent
mille euros de ca doit aller c'est à peu
près on va dire 120000 c'est non on
attend quoi c'est non ah ouais il est
frais et mes frères n'aura pas trop non
plus attends attends c'est le pack easy
way c'est pas fini je sais qu'on va pas
me plaindre mais il ya une chose que je
vais te dire c'est que mon mât tour au
prix ouais on m'a tout appris mais
vraiment toi comment tu avec un naturel
a volé un commentaire il faut que tu
sais même pas moi même tu ne sais même
pas trois mais je ne sais même pas moi
même taleo prisunic quand avait besoin
d'argent tu te servent et ouais tu te
serves voilà c'est c'était c'était
magnifique mais le plus important c'est
vrai que j'ai profité d'une situation
qui était bonne qui était vraiment bonne
mais la vérité j'en ai payé les
conséquences absence était alors on va
voir des extraits du documentaire parce
qu'il ya des extraits complètement fou
notamment à l'époque il avait accumulé
les millions d'euros vous avez vécu
comme des milliardaires moyens extrêmes
c'est quand vous allez à las vegas il ya
l'avion du mirage qui est un autre et
c'est le plus grand tunnel c'est un des
meilleurs hôtels voilà de de las vegas à
l'époque un qui vient vous chercher et
vous envoient leurs jets privés vont
revenir et c'est exactement pour venir à
las vegas jouer et on va voir la somme
que vous avez perdu il paraît qu'ils
étaient faites c'est important même de
perdre des sommes folles ouais par
exemple mais mal de 3 millions d'euros
ouais enfin je sais pas on n'a pas payé
ouais mais bon vous avez perdu gratuité
des gratuits on était des pigeons ça
veut dire que les mains qui nous
invitaient partout pour nous prendre
notre argent c'est à dire en réalité
nous on a fait de carbone mais tout le
monde derrière a fait carbone passe ils
ont donc tous profiter ça veut dire que
l'argent est parti ça veut dire quand
les mecs de las vegas qui nous a plaidé
été remis à l'eau tu vas venir tu joues
tu anh suite à six cas ça tu fais la
fête dabany allez on y voit je te prête
de l'argent à bout je me prépare à vous
prêter de l'argent ils me disent tu veux
3 millions il y est t'as pas 5
judiciaire quoi le risque que j'ai lu
m'a dit il vient puis en amérique 1 puis
à bonbons bien pu
qu'est ce que tu veux que je leur dise
regardez cet extrait
de 3 x 7 c'est un avion privé de las
vegas qui appartient wind et où il vient
chercher tous les plus gros clients ils
nous avaient installé il ya un orchestre
orientale pour nous amuser pour pour
nous distraire pour commencer leur
ambiance pour nous enlever l'argent
qu'on avait voilà
mais nous on s'éclatait dream on a vu
son unité des pigeons pomme
voilà c'est vrai que ça alors d'ailleurs
vous allez mettre philistins
qu'il a vu le documentaire
exactement mais là aussi que tu me suit
depuis très longtemps j'ai eu un grand
fan alors donc cette affaire sirigu sait
même pas combien d'argent vous avez
gagné non non vous avez fait quoi de
l'argent les plus ré moi je savais que
j'allais me faire arrêter ouais donc
j'ai dit plus gens dépensent vous êtes
s'arrêter à temps
alors le problème c'est que moi je me
suis mis en cavale ouais à cause je me
suis mis en cale parce que j'ai pris 8
ans j'ai pris le maximum ses dix ans
donc 108 ans je me suis dit mot la
prison avant m'attendent parce que j'ai
à faire et revenir bas sur les huit ans
ils sont là mais c'est parti à rome et
puis vous avez pris une photo de voir
hommes et puis après vous avez été
rattrapé en six ans j'ai fait le tour du
monde madame abonnés fait le tour du
monde du monde j'ai voulu savoir qu en
cavale est ce qu'on pouvait faire le
tour du monde donc le tour du monde
avant d'être récupéré et je pouvais
avoir un sourire aux larmes s'accorder
le regarder dans l'impôt c'est regarder
non il est pas les passants il est pas
beaucoup prennent que vous avez vous dit
la faire un sourire au pinceau je vous
pose une question parce que dans la
direction de l'agression
loubeau beaucoup
moins cher mais pour cyril met à lui
dire je me suis fait acquis pas c'est le
cas depuis 25 piges c'est vous
parce que j'ai vu le document est une
belle femme des contrats mais sur
islamistes ont voté blanc qui ment tard
j'ai raté du radio commentaires que j'ai
trouvé très très bien et je voulais
juste avoir parce qu'en fait vous en
parlez pas de ce tour du monde et
pourquoi giron par l'évêché un petit
bout quand même sympa presse mais c'est
pourquoi je comprends pas je vous ai
fait trois ans qu'il va mieux les deux
déjà et qui est pour moi je l'aimais pas
de sourire mais l'ouvreur
mais ses papiers de salle est toujours
belle et ça l'est toujours belle même
quand elle sourit pas bon alors vas-y
mariage suis pas obligé de sourire et
une injonction et ça veut dire qu'on
s'est bien débrouillé parce que moi je
vous souhaite à vous seriez là non pas
là
alors marco pourquoi pas parlé du tout
alors pourquoi j'ai pas parlé j'explique
or j'ai deux affaires en cours mais ils
sont assez importantes et j'ai monsieur
a marqué le procureur qui est bien
gentil mais quel numéro deux du poker du
parquet financier et le problème j'ai vu
j'ai vu dans la caméra qui m'aimait un
petit peu quand même je suis content
dans le documentaire c'est vrai qu'à un
moment on dit des mois sur le clip il
est quoi il écoute dodelet fait marrer
les salariés d'iss un cinglé mais j'aime
bien quand même voilà c'est en ce sens
que je vais me battre quand même dû les
passants levé il m'a récupéré tout est à
faire que d'aller à 30 ans non moi tu es
quoi ben hassine illuminations boulot
alors greg vous avez tant cavale pendant
deux ans avant de vous rendre ouais moi
je me suis rendu ouais ouais j'ai fait
deux fois j'ai eu de cavale j'en ai une
entre les etats-unis israël et une autre
à paris pendant 18 mois d'ailleurs tous
les procureurs pensais que j'étais
en israël où ailleurs alors j'étais à
paris pas loin sa balle a déjà l'air
scooter vous avez déjà fait une arnaque
to do c'est avec des mobiles téléphones
on en parle dans le documentaire hélas
le seo nommé parce que c'était une
arnaque moi je c'est en tout cas ce jeu
c'est un dessin pour de vrai donc je te
le promets que c'est vrai j'ai acheté
son restant savoir qu'est ce qui faisait
oui ça m'a coûté de l'oseille pour
acheter son restaurant j'ai dit espérons
que c'est vrai et lui après j'ai vu que
c'était alors racontez nous est un acte
de téléphone ce n'est pas restée avec la
tv 1 c'était même principe mais à
l'époque les qualifier ça comme de la
fraude fiscale donc c'était moins grave
ont gagné pratiquement autant d'argent
mais c'est à seulement ça a duré très
longtemps parce que bon il comprenait
pas où on avait plusieurs coups d'avancé
sur ce à quoi la fin c'est le système
européen les échanges de biens tout ça
ne s'est pas encore bien mis en place et
mais il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'inconvénients sur ceux sur cette façon
de travailler parce que les téléphones
c'est les produits à haute valeur
ajoutée c'est l'équivalent des iphone la
contient ou enfin des téléphones et
smartphones d'aujourd'hui et on avait
des problèmes j'allais stocker la
marchandise et les problèmes de vol il
fallait la transporter y avait toujours
des pertes il y avait des risques de
deux braquages les marchandises faille
et payer davance ans quand vous les
payez d'avancé vous avez des
fournisseurs qui étaient malhonnêtes et
puis après quand vous les vendez vous
allez même problème pareil vous pouvez
voir des gens qui sont malhonnêtes
c'était ces deux savait rien à voir avec
le co2 qui était en mai sommes bien en
gagner super man woman parler orient est
un mec moi qui m'a dit un jour avec le
co2 on arrivait parfois affaire de
chiffres d'affaires 500000 euros par
jour non puisque ça puisque ça varie
beaucoup puisque ça plus sympa rui aguas
millions mais auront millions et que
vous et vous êtes-vous resté combien
basse à ce qui vous a dit ça dépend
ça dépendra une dizaine de face à salé
pas enlever ou si tu es moi j'étais mon
batteur dépenser autant d'argent ce que
sa mère allait rénover un extrait est un
extrait dans le documentaire satirique
smadja qui dit regardez c'est très
compliqué de dépenser autant d'argent
tellement ça tombait du ciel en fait
c'est ça bon ben ce que ça pouvait
jamais s'arrêter ouais c'est tellement
simple qu'on ne s'est pas fait attention
on oser c'est ce qu'ils disent regardez
la pop le baril risque dit il n'importe
quelle personne les auraient cachés lui
en vérité peut-être qu'il avait peur il
voulait dépenser toute la journée
mais c'est dur à dépenser un mois
j'étais des films à dépenser sans sac de
105 par jour
alors c'est sûr des ponts sur moi je
trouve que c'est facile après chaque à
sa façon de dépenser moi la vérité ce
moment là j'ai free mais alors il ya des
gens qui disent ils est une énorme
escroquerie et au lieu de se cacher eux
ils et un manteau de fourrure sur les
champs elysées maintenant te fous rires
non pas en voilà mais c'était une façon
de parler
non il ya dépensé de l'argent il n'y a
pas plus facile tu vas l'âge légal déjà
cette coutume tonnes marco si vous vous
étiez cacher si vous aviez été un peu
plus ce que ça crée ce que vous auriez
pu continuer encore des années à quoi a
à faire c'est cette escroquerie ouais
vraiment
non mais c'est pas possible
techniquement parce qu'ils ont enlevés
ils soient perçus au bout d'un moment
ils sont venus la tva n'est pas
techniquement ils sont aperçus à le 40
milliards de personnes qu'ils ont
travaillé là dedans avant reviennent
normal qu'ils sont aperçus mais j'aurais
été seul alors été belle je sors a
appelé jeudi on travaille seul
taisez-vous bazire ou des bons
et autres problèmes c'est qu'est ce qui
met la puce à l'oreille des services
financiers de la police en fait c'est la
c30 vie dispendieux ou c ou c une
enquête poussée non pas du tout c'est
les services tracts faim qu'ils ont vu
que inouïe qui a plaidé
en fait ça a commencé entre face à ces
techniques séance a commencé entre la
caisse des dépôts et bercy
qui demandaient des remboursements tva
colossaux à bercy ça avait des soupçons
et après ils ont ouvert des enquêtes
pour savoir pour comprendre les circuits
financiers ou salés et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que
sans le concours de
enfin c'est par ils ont brillé c'est pas
un concours mais sans la caisse des
dépôts
ça c'était ça aurait jamais pu exister
mois dans dans un de mes dossiers par
exemple la caisse des dépôts elle a
envoyé à la balance et pour plus d'un
milliard d'euros pendant un an sur des
comptes en chine à chypre au monténégro
enfin dans des trucs âgées de la chine
c'est même pas un pays signataires des
protocoles du protocole de kyoto ils ont
rien vu pendant onze mois il envoyait
envoyé il envoyait les envoyer ils
paient des comptes dans ces pays-là
appartenant à des sociétés françaises je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
la faille quoi c est moi j'ai fait
l'erreur que j'ai eu c'est j'ai fait une
erreur d'évaluation qui n'ont pas
compris ça tu tremelo répéter mais bien
s'y fait c'est très important ce passage
là c'est très important je le raconte et
la caisse des dépôts d'habitude qu'on
fait une affaire dans le téléphone dans
quoi il suffit qu'on fasse cent mille
euros de chiffre d'affaires la traque ne
traquent fin arrive il nous bloque
l'argent même pourquoi réformer la wii
bon sens qui peut être que
je vais te dire donc la caisse des
dépôts nous envoyer dans un compte
à hong kong 10 millions d'euros puce la
tva ça veut dire qu'en réalité
c'est avec tout le respect que je dois
pour laquelle ces housses et des abrutis
ou alors ils l'ont fait exprès mais il
ya dans un problème c'était pas possible
les gérants
il avait 20 ans il savait même pas
parler
il n'y avait même pas d' enquête ni rien
donc c'est vrai que quand tu disais le
carbone c'était pour moi c'était pas
facile
c'était c'est dur il m'a appelé m'a dit
va là bas va faire ça et c'est bon voilà
un thème il n'y a pas de n'y a pas
d'affaires le téléphone ça a été un
boulot ça a été un vrai travail fallait
se lever à leurs cabanes c'était
beaucoup plus facile non c'est à dire
qu'ils avaient tous les avantages sans
les inconvénients de la téléphonie
mobile et ça c'est à dire que le canton
l'envoyaient en acheter des quotas
carbone ont payé à la caisse des pôles
on était sûr de passer replanter pour
décider de payer la livraison à l'été
instantanée en salle à la vitesse de
l'envoi d'un sms sur c'est instantané et
quand on se faisait payer après on
revendait la caisse des dépôts les mêmes
quotas plus tva il nous payait
instantanément si on était sûr de pas se
faire planter stis et il y avait tout
laissé ça que j'ai trouvé fascinant
c'est tous les avantages sans les
inconvénients de la téléphonie mobile
marco tu regrettes aujourd'hui ou pas du
tout ouais
il était dans le détroit du regret c'est
la vérité points
je regrette parce qu'il ya eu des choses
qu'ils ont pas été propre
et la vérité sincèrement moi je suis un
garçon sua excusez moi du terme menace
roule pas là je frime pas d'accord là
moi je non mais c'est la vérité moi
j'aime dépenser l'argent que je gagne
moi je sais pas ce qui peut arriver
demain dont tout ce que je crois c'est
pour le dépenser donc c'est pour ça que
je dis le carbone il ya eu trop de
mauvaises choses autour du carbone la
police
les impôts quand tu vas par exemple chip
tu vas y si tu vas ouvrir des comptes en
banque ces deux pour avoir le tekken 6
est la chose la plus dure au monde ça
arrive est arrivé à chypre bonjour qui
arrivait dans les banques on dirait des
pizzaïolos they can they can they can
carbone c'est à dire les pays entier
étaient au courant c'est comme la
comment j'ai réussi mon histoire moi
c'est grâce à la clape outil c'est grâce
aux traders c'est ça ce serait dans le
froid dans le dos et la terre arriva à
joindre un trader voilà et c'est lui qui
couvre toutes les noms et voudront rien
du tout bonjour apple j'ai dû à l'aube
de ce gène et de la caisse des dépôts et
des consignations
vous faites la tva le mec j'ai vu dans
le téléphone transpirer même le
téléphone il y avait de l'eau
arrive j'ai dit vous vous êtes il dit en
pologne chez c'est mon coup droit la
nuit au ritz au 800 rendez vous au ritz
moi il me reste un peu d'oseille si je
passais pas de ce coup là j'étais mort
d'accord et je l'aï s'est sauvé il avait
de l'oseille tout le monde avec
l'oseille j'ai été en pologne j'y arrive
je sois un mec vraiment pas beau mais
vraiment pas beau alors ça monte non non
non non on s'en fout pas quand mais
malkin on s'en fout pas parce qu'il est
tellement qu'ils étaient pas beau il
faisait peur
c'est la vérité je suis arrivé j'ai dit
bonjour j'étais sap à la perfection
bonjour monsieur bernier la caisse
dépôts et des consignations vous faites
la tva donc on est obligé de vous
arrêter et le mec il me dit ah non lui
comment non comment on fait il m'a dit
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire je suis
combien vous me donnez est là il m'a dit
on a associé est la vérité
c'est comme la chanson ce même monsieur
la matière tout en 2016 à fresnes acheté
un marteau m'a mis dans la merde je me
disais toute la journée ma vie dans la
bestialité bien
alors juste erika plein de gens qui
disent sur les réseaux vous avez les
retenir oui de votre arnaque à
vous êtes fier ou pas non pas du tout
non mais c'est comme ça non on ne peut
pas être fier au score qui sont honorés
par isis voilà c'est des millions
d'euros
est ce que vous dites et non il n'y a
aucune fierté à ce qu'on a fait enfin en
ce qui me concerne ce que j'ai fait
c'est complètement immoral et amoral si
c'était à refaire je le referais
absolument pas parce que ça que ça ne le
fait pas on dirait que tu m'as dit c'est
tout n'est reconnu devant la télé non tu
dis je le referai pas beke vertu duquel
charvaux non mais fier non mais ça y est
vous êtes le cerveau avant c'est ce
qu'on dit oui ils seront là c'est ce que
les rennais n'en est pas fière de quoi
d'être le cerveau non mais oui non si
y'a pas toi y'a pas de carbone et s'il a
besoin n'est pas de films web on
s'améliore mais si y'a pas toi jacques
l'instar de m non content et fier non
pas du tout mais il ya une chose que je
veux vous dire quand je fais un boulot
je le fais à fond donc quand tu fais une
arnaque que la revue moi aussi quand je
fais une arnaque tout la femme non non
je suis un boulot ou des drames aussi du
sien il ya une chose que je vais te dire
il ya une chose valérie je t'adore c'est
ce que je vais te dire tu adores pour de
vrai je te le promets que c'est vrai je
t'adore donc on va dans les paroles on
va bisounours il ya une chose que je
vais te dire ça veut dire de quoi
j'étais en train de parler à ma fait
couper la parole d'intelligence truc
dont je suis fier non on le fait à fond
quand vous faites un boulot le phare ou
mais non je ne vois pas le mal autour de
moi il ya une chose que je vais te dire
pied et c'est vrai n'importe qui saurait
non importe qui je dis bien n'importe
qui tu sais quand tu es dans un boulot
tzigane de l'osec comme ça la vérité tu
vois pas le mal tu vois que le bien les
hypocrites tu crois que c'était un ami
je faisais 400 kg me disait que j'étais
beau nom mais je savais pas que c'était
l'odeur qui était beau mais je faisais
400 kg et enfin de te rappelles oui oui
tu te rappelles toi tu étais bon tous se
disaient que c'était pour moi d'ailleurs
et voilà donc à une chose que je vais te
dire d'être fiers d'avoir fait ça non
d'avoir
d'avoir un bon boulot oui voila je pose
une question pour sa bien clair l'argent
les deux cent mille euros c'est l'argent
donc du contribuable on est bien
d'accord pour être clair ou c'est
l'argent de nos sociétés et les
payeurs partout moi j'ai une question
pour marco valli le film de netflix est
un documentaire mais votre personnage il
est tellement fort et tellement
fascinant pour dire un personnage de
fiction est ce que vous avez envie ou
est ce qu'on vous a déjà proposé de
jouer dans un film où est-ce qu'on vous
l'a demandé oui on vous a proposé de
faire une série amicalement vôtre ah oui
et puis on est en train de chercher mon
me nomme mon and home et je pense que tu
y vas y toi
non
[Applaudissements]
question j'écoute mois cette question je
les attends écoute moi depuis que tu es
rentré sur
écoute moi j'avais envie de te parler
mais ton sourire je pense qu'elle va
être belle bah doucement c'est tout
c'est une question très simple et
peut-être peut-être naïve j'aimerais
savoir si vous aviez caché de l'argent
au cas où ça se passait mal quelque part
dans le monde et si vous ne l'avez pas
fait ce que vous le regrettez alors
explique toi parce que du coup latapie
d'argent alors je t'explique moi tu sais
quand je suis arrivé de quand j'étais à
paris quand j'étais plus jeune j'avais
qu'une qu'une seule cassette vidéo robin
des bois et j'avais envie d'être dans ce
film robin des bois donc ma vie c'est du
robin des bois toute ma vie n'est
acquis par donna qui marque 20 qui vous
avez donné alors il ya une chose que je
vais vous dire madame que je respecte
énormément parce que vous êtes
une photo à vous tout seul sincèrement
c'est vrai ça se ressent un compliment à
sac une diapo donc savez pourquoi c'est
un compliment parce qu'une photo ça
reste tout le temps la même nom on peut
changer et c'est la vérité monsieur
n'avait pas répondu j'étais en train de
répondre moque malade alors allez-y
précédant le combat xi
skies n'aura quelques pas ekwalla poser
la question qu'est ce que vous avez fait
pour donner aux pauvres c'est ça
ouais mais savez il ya des documents de
dire que l'argent combien j'en ai déjà
donné 30 % de l'argent que j'ai gagné au
monde entier aux bonnes oeuvres à
aubenas épicier marqué à des écrits le
plus important c'est dans les
dépositions c'est pas moi qui le dis si
les juges alors c'est pour ça que les
juges eux-mêmes bien marc aubry on vous
la portez des gants ouais depuis
longtemps pour quel motif à pour quel
motif si un jour tu veux venir me voir
tout va t'appeler après marre que les
gens pareils enfin cyril élégant c'est
parce que j'aime la sape mois pour moi
cela qu'a inventé le mot l'habit fait
pas le moine
franchement
quand on sape tout le monde est bien
dans tapoter sait à la perfection de
tout maintenant l'avantagent comme tu en
parles je m'habille richard valentine à
ces milliers de sites et d'autres
marques ballon
alors il samedi je fais l'ouverture
nourrichard valentin martin parle très
bien passé très bon alors là bravo bien
sûr aval qui année là sur la mode à
petit prix la baisse marco et
greg on va voir un extrait dans le
documentaire on entend également se
produire si vous nous rejoignez sait on
parle de l'arnaqué du siècle cette
arnaque au co2 et il ya un documentaire
sur netflix qui cartonne actuellement
dans le documentaire notons également le
procureur patrice amar kate clark hyper
sympa moi je trouve dans le documentaire
moi j'ai trouvé d'arcadie les minarets
tu vas voir si les darker
team
ltg ses patrons il persévère dans le
document des jetons mais sympathique
city qui t'aime bien j'aime bien ces
caisses qui m'a fait lui raconte
l'histoire bah si mais je te raconte
deux minutes et humer le coutelas je
sais qu'ils voient et je sais que tous
les palais tous les cons dévoilé
l'émission d'accord je tiens bien dans
les angoisses
attrait flip de haut à droite on
attend d'ailleurs on va en parler de
vote dont certains sont inquiets pas
alors vas-y
les pages ans je voulais dire non non
j'ai deux affaires en cours dont la
responsable est mené on aime et je te
jure les jeux toujours comme j'ai trouvé
sympa gentil je vous jure que par sa
barre et ben moi j'aurais trouvé il perd
bien dans le dos le documentaire inédit
qui t'aime bien il s'est marré quand il
a vu la musique ils te disent un
cinquième a pris 8 bis gym a fait ouais
mais bon on n'a plus qu'un pas que
d'argent qui a procuré leurs patins des
clauses et on
demande 10 ans mais elle est tout a été
fabriqué les bail que tu as vu mon
procès non je peux marquer je suis quoi
moi je suis juif oui il met deux
procurant juif et un président soit tête
de ma mère carvalho vente donc moi pour
casser l'ambiance j'arrive avec un café
à 9h30 à la place de 9h et le président
et commence à crier et julien tendu
arrive paf 30 minutes en retard at-on
procès mais arrivés trente minutes en
retard ouais
[Rires]
c'est un ami louis brouillard ils sont
donnés à nouveau mais quand il est
arrivé
il est l'atout il est là luis alors non
je suis là combien de temps
cela ok ok ça fait pas longtemps non
mais moi je serais toi comment cela
demain d'histoire a alors mais dans quoi
que tu voulu nommer il ya quelque chose
qui me gêne c'est que vous êtes sympa
vous êtes drôle vous gesticulez partout
mais à la fin de ce documentaire d'un
resserrement
la partie un compliment partie deux
vérités vous avez quand même volé de
l'argent enfin ces milliards ces
milliards une rossée millions d'euros
c'est de l'argent qui doit aller dans
les écoles c'est de l'argent qui doit
aller dans les hôpitaux vous dites
j'irais reverser 30% à des associations
mais bon avec 70% durée vous avez tout
dépenser dépenser 20 % il ya quelque
chose qui me gêne c'est que derrière ce
documentaire est votre personnage vous
fait rire tout le monde et moi même j'ai
souri au moins dix fois mais derrière ça
fait un petit peu oublié que ce que vous
avez fait c'est exact d'accord alors tu
lui réponds et on parle sérieusement
alors ya une chose que je vais te dire
qu'il croit que sincèrement et ne la
fait pas trop lourd il ya une chose que
je vais te dire quand ils vont campagne
les politiciens ils prennent 20 millions
français chacun ils font leur campagne
pour de la politique d'accords pour ça
il y en a qu'un qui président le rêve
sont pas président mais c'est dans la
continuité
dans la course et dégage
moi je fais partie de la constitution
[Rires]
si les comptes de campagne sont
falsifiés sont condamnés monsieur c'est
normal ah oui évidemment il doit être
condamné oui bon je m'emploie faire cinq
mois mais pourquoi alors moi tu vois pas
être condamné non pourquoi mais déjà
décote est une escroquerie
dis moi dis vertébrale et même si on
attend on s'en fout des centres c'est
pas l'argent qui compte c'est le plus
important c'est de savoir le faire il ya
une chose que je ne te dire j'ai pas
fais que ça dans ma vie je sais gf 18
ans j'ai une boîte cotée en bourse à 22
ans j'en ai une autre le seul problème
que j'ai c'est que j'ai des trous dans
la poche pas d'accord et quand je fais
une affaire
je ne vois pas que c'est une arnaque ou
pas une arnaque j'avance mais la seule
différence c'est 50 prison tôt oreilles
tu n'as pas pris comme moi parce que
deux secteurs un escroc mais fait deux
jours tu voir comment tu seras tu vas
voir comment tu seras ça ça valait le
coup de quoi certainement ajoutant cinq
ans de prison
ça valait le combat annoncé à refaire je
referais pas vraiment vous avez vraiment
est en prison ou brassier les bienvenus
shannon à
4h30 sur des souris âgées rien fait
vous n'avez pas fait de petit con tu as
fais toi non et 5 ans moi tu as fait tu
vois pas qui divise en papa m'a jamais
vraiment été en prison si jamais je
n'aurais pas été en prison bon serait
pas même électronique parce qu'il ya
aussi
cinq ans de prison vous n'êtes pas très
bon on affaire judiciaire
non mais non c'est pas si l'ancien qu'à
jouer la c1
[Applaudissements]
c'est maintenant tu me reconnais
et c'était lui
avec écoute moi il ya un truc que je
vais te dire qu'à rester le même à ce
jour la vérité marc est de free mais
aussi
ils t'adorent table et vous avez dû
alors si en plus rares comme marco ya et
organise déjà remis tu vas
exceptionnelle pour ton fils vernis
excuse moi tu en a rien à [ __ ] de ce
qu'il te dit il j'ai envie de la guedra
est alors fait des compliments il est
beau but de tapoter bien ici elle votre
c'est vous qui vous déplacer
et isabelle isabelle je t'aime
que tu auras mon numéro de téléphone me
manquera un chiffre fais-toi malades
[Applaudissements]
changer de numéro je voudrais te dire
non ne change pas de numéro de téléphone
pour les conduis moi mais je sais mais
je change pour toi quand j'en doute
appelée je t'appelle ya un truc que je
veux dire aussi je suis marié ah oui si
je reçois beaucoup je reçois beaucoup de
matches à plat le truc la
cdapp des navettes était marié j'aime ma
femme que le 10 dans le chien dit dans
l'île tu le dis dans le sont ailleurs
non mais je laime way dans son île oui
quoi je suis encore moi j'avais pas moi
je sais pas chez les juifs durant son
divorce
ça arrive à
moi je vais jamais été mariée deux fois
oui
cheryl arrête
toi qui leur aux autres pas moi à
l'aller ça fait trente piges que je
tenais
revenir à 30 pour
la bar mitzvah exceptionnelle de ton
fils ouais plein d'invités c'est un truc
de fou regardez les images regardent ils
dorment ici
tu manges tu bois tu fais la pète et
oublie lendemain mais qui vit passer les
benêts
y avait gardé de parler il y avait
nicolas colorée inspirée et avait une
pompe au rabat m pokora là il y avait
kazuya levé maître gims
[Musique]
y avait eu
c'est vrai est élevé moins sur le bois
ça
mais c'est vrai que ouais mais j'ai pas
fai avec la halle est où là chez elle
j'ai pas fait car dit il je m'appelle
géraldine chez moi c'est quoi selon lui
à 30 ans non c'est mignon géraldine très
bas dans ce jardin des voix derrière
comme elle est belle elle est
massif et nerveux n'est pas belle si
le sujet vous alors allez-y parler je
n'ai pas fait ça avec l'argent du
carbone il ya une chose que je veux vous
dire quand ils sont venus m'arrêter et
mon tout enlever d'adresser sa soeur et
mon primé maison hugo tout prix mais mon
prix de l'argent d'avant aussi donc j'ai
vraiment perdu beaucoup moi ça veut dire
qu'en réalité et sincèrement je vous le
dis j'ai rien gagné vous avez perdu
combien mais limitant pas de vie déjà en
millions d'euros à peu près beaucoup tu
veux te sollicite le dis à toi tu auras
malade est un conseil cautionnons non
mais il a envie d'avoir malade
grec belgique ont été gagnés ce qu'on
appelle maintenant ça va à peu près grec
mois des entrepreneurs est vous n'êtes
pas capable dans mes classes et non mais
c'est pas ça c'est allé gagner combien
200 millions d'euros de quoi
être 23 millions mais moi je dois moi
non pour moi et pour lui et moi j'en ai
trois mois je dois 283 millions d'euros
il ya une chose que je vais te dire on
se revoit dans le sérieux ans je me
donne trois ans pour les rembourser je
le dis devant les juges quoi qu'il
arrive je rembourserai ma dette et je
serai quitte voilà c'est de l'honneur
que je me mets mais ils m'ont mis quand
même huit ans de prison
mais c'est normal et c'est l'institut
met à l'argent vous avez des pensées
aussi ya ce que vous avez dépensé ça
vous en avez profité que tu nettoyer les
oreilles
bien j'ai dit tahrir mais d'accord mais
vous pourrez pas vous plaindre et qu'on
revienne parce qu'on a vu on a vu toute
l'épopée las vegas détruits c'est quoi
le truc le plus fou que s'est effectué
alors ce qu'il ya alors n'ya rien truc
que j'ai fait c'est qu'est-ce qui l'a
raconté le procureur est ce que je vous
ai parlé d'une légende aussi je voudrais
raconter téléspectateurs une histoire
qu'on m'a raconté sur toi est ce que
c'est une légende ou pas une histoire de
pato merguez
dans un restaurant qui n'en faisaient
pas et tu leur ennemi je veux des pâtons
arias que ça donc c'est vrai chez
ducasse c'est ça ouais alors racontez
nous l'histoire c'est quoi eh ben je
suis arrivé j'avais tu sais quand tu vas
en boitant envie de sortir tu as envie
d'aller manger et puis j'avais envie de
manger des pâtes aux merguez way et le
problème c'est qu'il y avait pas de
merguez cacher je mange casher enfin
halal casher c'est pareil c'est
important que des ouais bien sûr que
c'est important que je me dis que je
veux pas remettre de la saucisse
nourriture parce que tu veux
et je leur ai demandé et je l'aurai ne
sais qui tu étais chez ducasse il veut
pas dire le nom sacré dû faire de la pub
c'est un très grand restaurant étoilé
et je leur ai demandé d paterberg et ils
m'ont dit il y en a pas ici des pato
bergen on comprend pas c'est quoi les
pâtes aux merguez judy diminue tu fais
des pâtes au mariage stimuleront il m'a
dit combien geof
sinon elle est bien j'en fais donc c'est
ça que je te dirai aussi l'argent
l'argent il est beau quand envie qui
soit beau après le problème c'est qu'il
est il ya des parfois qu'il ait pas
beaucoup chez me d'avoir de l'argent que
deux bars d'avoir quand même cc 1 voilà
c'est quoi le truc que tu as fait le
plus fou tôt à greek
j'ai fait fermer hermès pour ma femme
non ah oui à la classe away complètement
fermée donnez combien on pense à cannes
on consommait beaucoup d'occasions au
nord est à consommer pour combien elle
l'a quitté
vous avez des pensées à peu près je suis
plus mais c'est estelle examineront
comment à wimille on bosse hier même si
c'est cher mais c'est du lourd mais
alors la justice et celle après les
trucs hermès du coup ils sont déjà
privés non non il n'a pas le droit ou
vêtements tu as eu les vêtements toi
tous les pompes et tout un week avait
des larmes a envie avec moi s'emballe
moi je trouvais arrêté est arrêté en
2009 j'étais le premier donc alors marco
si quand tu t'es fait arrêter s'est
passé comment
alors ils m'ont fait un coup de wisches
les douaniers je leur dis devant eux
bravo bravo j'avais caché un peu
d'argent et je me suis dit [ __ ] ça va
ya pas de bruit dabadie dabaga hockey et
là les doigts de me convoque pour une
affaire qu'il avait rien à voir avec moi
je savais pas que j'avais rien à voir
avec moi soit une convocation de douane
je m'excite j'ai un peu d'argent la
super excitant catch prend une valise et
je me sauve en israël j'arrive à
l'aéroport de roissy et je me dis ma
attend s'ils veulent rattraper pour
aller en prison ils viennent me chercher
n'en voyais pas une convocation donc
j'ai laissé partir ma valise tout seul
et je suis parti j'étais aux douanes
mais c'est là où ils m'ont eu je suis
arrivé bonjour monsieur mouly bonjour
vous savez est ce que vous connaissez ma
quid en ami à moi une autre équipe est
ce que vous connaissez matuidi ouais
c'est un ami et me dit ok gaza et
services à jeudi
vous savez que je dois aller chercher
mes enfants à l'école mais les enfants
ils ont 70 ans
est ce que vous savez je vais aller
chercher pour savoir si ça oui pas de
problème dans deux heures tu es dehors
et moi je n'y croyais pas et là ils
m'ont fait ils m'ont dit requiem se
mouiller on voir je suis dis à bientôt
dit non on n'a pas besoin est là ils
m'ont et c'est là où ils m'ont laissé
m'envoler sortir l'argent dépensé et là
ils m'ont accueilli comme une et c'est
pour ça qu'à six heures du matin quand
ils sont arrivés j'y croyais pas donc
ils sont arrivés dont qu'ils étaient
devant la porte et s'est fait comme ça
chez disney qui me dit tu sais c'est
nous c'est la police je vais par la
fenêtre parce que j'habite au premier je
veux par la fenêtre pour mais pour pour
me sauver et je vois une meuf une fille
qui a fait ça
je reviens et je vous la passe je vous
la porte à une seule condition il dit qu
à marco oui me connaissent et me
connaissait et judith quoi je bois mon
petit déjeuner tu réveilles pas mes
enfants et la perquisition qui l'a fait
tout il me dit pas de problème mais ben
non moi je m'excite j'avais un peu de
sous je voulais les cacher donc j'ai
caché ma mangent ils ont tous trouvé un
voilà à la fin je me suis battu avec eux
laisse moi 2000 pour la prison
laisse-moi 3000 une dijonnaise 1100
juive asiad 10000 c'est pour avoir marre
on s'est tapé pendant trois heures je
regrette en veillée la perquisition
l'hautil à la base unique est une
faisait toi là bas tu as volé quelque
chose mais pour dégoûter la perquisition
il ya une chose que je vais te dire moi
j'ai vu moi j'ai eu des problèmes avec
la brigade financière avec les douanes
la vérité sur la vérité aujourd'hui tout
cela qu'ils veulent et ce coquet ou qui
veulent voler ils ont des moyens de tout
savoir donc un conseil que coordonne
rester droit d'envoi lot parce que je
veux dire avaient été des douanes cd pas
trop c'est des vrais patrons quand ils
arrêtent ils savent pourquoi et ça
pourquoi internet c'est fini tu es mort
là-haut jour aujourd'hui tu tu feras
plus jamais rien d'illégal non parce que
si je suis beaucoup plus bon dans légal
ou illégal c'est pour moi mon ego ouais
c'est pour être meilleur que les autres
meilleurs que lui mais peu de la
complicité
c'est d'ailleurs que tout le monde j'ai
pas un truc où j'ai été numéro un ça
veut dire que j'ai pas en six mois de
retard en trois mois j'ai rattrapé tout
le monde c'est juste pour faire montre
et à moi même que je suis meilleur que
tout le monde mais en réalité dans les
affaires normal propre nickel j'en fais
autant même beaucoup mieux ses propres
sites lève le matin tu as ton petit
costume ta petite cravate sûrs en compte
des mecs comme ça ils te disent thébaux
marco toute la journée
n'a pas affaire à la police aujourd'hui
vous vous estimez avoir payé votre dette
avec les années de prison vous avez fait
grégory moi j'ai fait quatre ans et demi
ouais et je suis encore
sous le régime de la libération
conditionnelle j'ai pas fini encore
maintenant je me fais payer ma dette non
je finirai jamais il faudrait dix vies
pour te rembourser mahbod dollar j'avais
honte de ça ou pas du tout oui
aujourd'hui marine est à refaire je le
referais pas du tout et on veut dire
août non mais c'est à dire quoi la d2 ce
que tu as fait ou non mais en fait le
fait de venir comme ça à la télé dans un
faisceau de la non mais ce film là on
est venu nous chercher parce que nous
fascine marco toi toi tu vois pas posé
la question à ce sujet toi j'ai fait ce
film ouais alors jeté lui attend leur
déjà des châteaux et estime avoir payé
sa dette ou pas ah non je leur dois
toujours way en osant même on n'osait y
voit l'état des prisons tout à fait
pourquoi cette société très dur je
souhaite à personne je dirai arrêtez ces
affreux quand tu es devant la porte et
là avec ta machine à camphin avec ton
café avec les choses est assez horrible
tu crois la question fait montre est
alors sur quintana pas content la koh
lanta on va en parler quant à la voie
lactée par ailleurs en prison la paire
de chaussettes le café l'eau chaude
c'est affreux c'est pas ta bille et plus
rien d'un numéro d'écrou ouais ce n'est
pas ma vie et vous peuvent garder
d'ailleurs par les prisonniers un patin
de rien si si si si l'entraidé belles
fringues cie si vous avez de belles
fringues houphouet jettent en costume
pense me promener on a ça sert à rien il
faut lui nier fois j'allais au
restaurant
comment ça bah oui tu veux que je
raconte la prison de suisse tu vois
rigoler ouais j'aurais alors live à
aller bien cela non mais écoute moi bien
je connais très bien voilà jeter aux
téléspectateurs à la télé on n'est pas
la raison l'a
alors
de suisse c'est la plus belle chose de
ma vie parce que là je suis devenu fou
faut prendre exemple est là pour de vrai
j'arrive imac rappelé au delà takacs
marque on peut faire assène fille ruth a
eu bon toutes les polices voulais
m'arrêter mais sympa que j'ai fait le
tour du monde pendant huit mois d'abord
ce que j'ai voulu me faire arrêter j'ai
voulu me rendre j'en avais marre et
j'arrive à la truck de la prison et on
doit mettre à chalandon en prison et le
directeur de la prison il fait quand
même dit monsieur mouly je dis oui mais
dans ce sens prise ou moins que tu m'as
en france les bana qui te dire désolé
monsieur mouly tout est bien le sage on
sait bien que oui ça va moi je me suis
pris à manger oui ça va ils me disent
donc voilà je on a deux blocs un des
travailleurs un pub de payer la prison
je pense que je vais payer il m'amène
dans le bloc qui me dit alors voix et
c'est là où je suis devenu fois rapport
à la france en ont mais regarde qu'est
ce que je vais te dire le mec il me dit
alors première était à 130 euros 2e
étage 300-400 la tête j'ai pris la suite
non fois tu es bien sûr pour avoir 100
m² commun commun à présent
630 par mois ah ouais par ben par osho
par mois
on pourrait dire deux cent mille euros
par jour alors ce n'est pas qu'ils
avaient plutôt osé
c'est
dur des trucs du seo est truqué les
dictionnaires pour commencer à appeler
son poste là comme toute la
machine a sélectionné non animateurs et
m'a marqué eric je
n'étais pas né encore